we're asked to convert pi radians and
negative PI over 3 radians to degrees so
the first question I'll ask you if you
do 1 revolution if you have an angle
that went all the way around once how
many radians is that well we know that
that is 2 pi 2 pi radians now that exact
same angle if we were to measure it in
degrees how many degrees is that well
you've heard of people doing a 360 doing
one full revolution that is equal to 360
degrees
now can we simplify this it's important
to write this little little superscript
circle that's literally the unit's under
question sometimes it doesn't look like
you know but it is a unit you could
literally write degrees instead of that
little symbol and the unit's right here
of course are the word radians now can
we simplify this a little bit well sure
both 2 pi and 360 or divisible by 2 so
let's divide things by 2 and if we do
that what do we get for what PI radians
are equal to well on the left-hand side
here we're just left with PI radians PI
radians and on the right-hand side here
360 divided by 2 is 180 and we have
still the units which are degrees so we
get PI radians are equal to 180 degrees
which actually answer the first part of
our question we wanted to convert pi
radians well we just figured out pi
radians are equal to 100 180 degrees PI
radians are equal to 180 degrees and if
you want to think about it
we know PI radians are halfway around a
circle halfway around a circle like that
well and that's the same thing as 180
degrees so now let's think about the
second part of it we want to convert
negative PI over 3 radians I'm just in a
new color negative PI over 3 so negative
PI over 3 radians how can we convert
that to degrees what do we get based on
this information right over here well to
figure this out we need to know how many
how many degrees there are
a Radian if we need to multiply this
times degrees and I'm going to write the
word out because if I just wrote a
little circle here it would really it'd
be hard to visualize that as as unit
degrees per degrees per Radian so how
many degrees are there per Radian well
we know that for every 180 degrees for
every 180 degrees we have pi radians we
have pi radians or you could say that
there are 180 over PI degrees per Radian
and this is going to work out we have
however many radians we have times the
number of degrees per Radian so of
course the units are going to work out
radians cancel out the pie also cancels
out the pie also cancels out and 180 so
you're left with negative 180 divided by
3 leaving us with what is that negative
60 negative 60 and we don't want to
forget the units we could write them out
that's the only unit says left degrees
which we could write out we could write
out the word degrees or we could just
put that little symbol there